okay I'm Haji and I'm journalist Oh from
China not quickly it's the second time I
take part in the summer hours for me the
most impression is China become to a
more animal pay attention to for the
world and a lot of people believe China
is the most and the Magister goes
markets in the world and reject nuys
China had their own knowledge to show
the world China had as much confidence
to become were strong and powerful so as
I think the sum of dollars is a good
chance to show us and china me working
together with other countries and and
other people's let me share knowledge
and share the ideas so I sa is a good of
you to notice the Chinese mijo thank you
very much